Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two
lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time, I'm Rhett...
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
Rhett's taking me on a
cross-country road trip.
Vroom, vroom.
I've been waiting to hear...
Ah, I bet you have.
About this Road-trip.
Well, the moment I heard,
when I was back here in LA,
you were still in North Carolina,
your trip to Mexico was disintegrating
right before your eyes
and I was feeling sorry for you,
and then all of a sudden, Christie's like,
because she's reading
the thread and I'm not
because I'm in full vacation mode.
She's like "Rhett and Locke,
they're gonna drive back to LA."
they're doing a cross-country road trip.
Best idea ever.
I've got admit...
Jealous.
Yeah, it's like immediate jealousy.
Like this sinking side, It's like...
Well, why didn't they invite me?
Just wait until you had all the story.
If you invited me,
that's not how cross-country trips work,
I was on the other coast already,
that's why you didn't invite me.
I could've picked you up
and taken you to my house in
the last like half mile or so.
No, but like, the whole
week after Christmas
that we were all on break,
I was like, "Let's do something guys."
And I could always rent a van again,
and we can do a couple of nights camping.
There was like torrential...
It was raining like crazy here.
Pouring of rain here, it was depressing,
didn't want to go out,
but it was relaxing.
But I wanted to do something
and they wanted it to just chill out.
I respected that, but I
was a little frustrated.
And then on top of that, it's like,
man, he's got this like father-son thing.
Bonding.
seeing places, I've only
done one cross-country trip.
And it wasn't when my son...
It was with me.
Yeah, it was.
Similar route that I took.
So I want to hear all about it.
You've been saving it
to tell me on this podcast.
Even a couple of times,
we've been amongst friends
who wanted to hear about the
trip and you've been there
and I had to say, I can't talk
about it because Link's here.
People are like, "These
guys are so weird."
I can't tell you about my trip
because I have to wait until now.
I mean, they understood.
They laughed because I was like,
"Listen, I don't want to
have to act not bored,
hearing it a second time on my podcast."
That's more important than
us talking about it now,
than our friendship.
Hopefully, you're the kind of
Ear Biscuits here/Mythical Beast
who listens to every
episode of Ear Biscuits
so you already know that COVID changed
my plans to go to Mexico,
and then I decided to go on a road trip.
I'm not going to tell any more than that.
But I wanted it...
Why was it me and Locke?
Like why was me and my 17-year-old son
and not my 13-year-old son?
Well, my 13-year-old son,
very likely got COVID over the break
and that's why we just
didn't go to Mexico.
And so Locke and I have been planning
on taking a trip together, maybe during...
We've been trying to get go...
Can we close that loop? He's fine.
Yeah, yeah. Shepherd's totally fine.
Shepherd is double vaccinated
so he experienced essentially a cold,
he was down for a couple
of days and he's back.
We never confirmed that that's what he had
because all we had was those at-home tests
and so we're just assuming
that's what he had.
But if it's me,
and I'm not going to put
these thoughts and words in your mouth
and I don't want to throw you
under your family bus here,
but if it were me and I was in
your situation at that point,
I would've been like,
"This presents a unique opportunity
for me and Lincoln to
travel across the country,
without the other siblings."
I mean, doing a cross-country
road trip as a family
is a totally different thing
than just doing it with one son,
it's a different concept.
We actually considered.
It was on the table for us to all go
because actually by the time we left
Shepherd was essentially recovered,
but Locke and I specifically,
have been trying to plan a trip together.
We were going to go to Japan
and then we were going to go to,
I don't know, somewhere else.
And then, COVID has changed
our plans multiple times
and so, this is a trip
that's been in the making,
and he's going to graduate
high school this year...
So it's not about avoiding
spending time with your
whole family in one car,
but that I had to think that was
a little bit of a fringe benefit.
Well, all it took, as
Jessie and I discussed it
for about 15 seconds, as I was like,
"You know how our family is so intense,
that there's a chance that
all four of us in a car
could disintegrate really quickly?"
I mean, there was a chance that
me and Locke in car could
disintegrate very quickly,
but the chances were lower.
Now, interestingly, I've
talked a little bit about Locke
and his tendency to be...
He's an Enneagram Eight,
he's a challenger,
and so one of the things that I have found
to be consistently true
is when you have an idea,
even if it's a great idea,
like a cross-country road trip,
his initial reaction to it
will be one of doubt and skepticism.
It's always instinctive.
Oh yeah, and I knew that
was going to happen.
And lo and behold, when
I pitched the idea of,
"Hey, man, day after Christmas,
let's just drive back to Los Angeles."
It wasn't an immediate, like,
"This is a great idea."
It was like, "How many hours
is that going to be in the car?"
Like these were the questions, right?
It's a legit question.
I don't want to spend too
much time on this point
because obviously we ended up going
but the way that I kind
of went into a dad-pitch
and Jessie was involved and we
did a little bit of good cop,
actually good cop, good cop.
But I just said,
listen, it's very difficult
for the future Locke
to understand what is
being proposed right now.
And that is, cross-country
trips of any kind...
Well, future Locke is not
here, he's in the future.
Right, you know what I mean?
It is very difficult for
your future-self to look...
You can't look back and appreciate
what you are about to experience
in a cross-country trip.
And also as someone who
has lived in adult life
for some time, I know how hard it is
to come by a cross-country trip.
These aren't things that
just present themselves,
but I've never met someone who was like,
"I regret my cross-country trip.
I really regret it."
Now, I'm sure there are people who do,
but most people are like,
when I think about some of
the formative experiences,
the things that I remember
in my life, oh, that cross-country trip.
Like these are formative
experiences and memories
and I was like,
"You're not going to regret going on this.
You will regret saying no, potentially."
So you sold the experience
in your future-self will thank you.
Yeah, I've had to do that
a number of times with him.
I mean, did you say,
"And you know what,
we're going to be announcing our location
and meeting with fans
of mine at rest stops
off the interstate all across America....
All I did was...
It will severely slow down our progress.
As we stopped at multiple rest stops.
During the first rest-stop stop I did say,
there was a point in
time about a decade ago
where Link and I did a cross country trip
and stopped and announced to our fans
that we were stopping
at various rest stops.
And instead of thinking
it was weird he was like,
"That's cool, man."
It was cool.
It was.
If you're interested in that,
you can just Google Mythical Road Trip.
The videos are spread across
two different channels.
Of course this is pre-GMM,
so, across the GMM channel
and the main channel.
Do some work to piece it
together for yourself,
maybe there's a playlist.
I'm going to be,
I took a lot of video,
took a lot of pictures,
including we took a couple of
those disposable film cameras
that apparently take a week to develop,
that's why they're not developed here.
Oh, like a wedding.
Yeah, but between all
of that visual media,
if you're just listening to the podcast,
just know that the YouTube version of this
is going to have a lot
of that visual stuff.
I'll show you some, if it's
needed for context, as we go.
I'll watch the video,
Or you can just watch later.
I'll watch the YouTube video.
But I don't want to spend
a lot of time on my phone.
How much planning did you have?
So, you sold him?
Pick up where you left off here.
He was like "I'll do it, dad."
We were going to leave on the 26th.
Did he have any
stipulations, was he like...
Well, one of the things that he had to do
is he had, he had two things to do,
he's taking a German course
that's outside of his school
because before he transferred
high schools a long time ago
he was he was in the German curriculum
and so he needs to finish
to like, get to like,
think he's doing it, AP German,
I don't know what it is.
Was it like car
manufacturing, what was it?
It was just the language of Germany.
Oh, just the language.
And so he needed to do that
because he's got to finish
it by like mid-January
so he needed to spend
some time doing homework.
He's also currently
applying to more colleges
than the ones he's already applied to
so we needed to do some
essays and stuff like that.
And I was like, "Listen,
we've got this giant SUV
that's way too big for us,
it's super comfortable,
it's like a mobile classroom.
It's like one of those
families that has a school bus
that just takes their kids around
doing homework all the time."
So, there'll be plenty of
opportunity for homework
because I'm going to
drive, it's a rental car,
you're not allowed to drive this thing
so, you're going to be able
to do a lot of homework.
He was like,
"Yeah, okay, okay, yeah, all right."
But this is like the
23rd or so, 22nd, 23rd
when we made the call to
cancel the Moscow trip
and decided to do this.
So in terms of preparation,
I actually, I let Jenna know
that I was doing this
cross-country road trip
and she was like,
"Well, you should check out
the website roadtrippers.com."
And I did, and that was actually,
thank you for that, Jenna,
that was very helpful
because what you end up doing
is you basically go on there
and you set your destination,
your origin and your destination,
and then it creates a
corridor around the route,
like a 30 mile wide corridor,
which in my case was on 40,
because I was going to take 40
because I didn't want to just go.
I wanted to get home,
but I wanted to be able to
experience some stuff as well.
But I didn't want to
do one of these things
where you're like going up north.
Also, winter weather was happening
and I'll talk a little
bit more about that,
we actually had a divert
our route because of that,
but I wanted to stay 40 or south,
I didn't want to go too far to the north.
I mean, it's a cool site where you just,
you see things organized by
category and you click on them
and you can just add them to your trip.
Then it's like, it automatically
sends that navigation
to your navigation app on your phone.
So you've got the mobile app,
you've got the computer
and with the information
and people's reviews of
these different places
and things to do.
Do I have to buy a subscription for this?
Here's how they get you,
so, I'm sitting there planning my trip
and I'm about like four
or five destinations in
or four or five stops
in and then it was like,
"To add a seventh destination
or for unlimited destination adding,
please sign up for subscription service."
And I was like, boy, I've
spent an hour so far doing this
and so it was genius system
and so I ended up paying
like the yearly fee
to basically subscribe to the thing.
But I don't regret it.
Even know the chances of using it again,
they know are very low, even for you.
Yeah, well, I'm going to not pay again
or I'll probably forget and pay again.
Exactly.
This is how they make their
money and I have no regrets.
Right.
And so all we knew is that
we wanted to get to LA
by like New Year's Eve.
So if you go from the
26th to New Year's Eve,
that's a total of six days.
Me and you went pretty aggressively
when we went with our Yu Ha,
and I think we did five days or so.
I think it was either four
or five, it was not six.
I'm 100% sure of it.
How did we do that?
Well, it's not that hard as
you're about to find out,
even when you take multiple stops,
more stops than me and you did.
The only stop we took for
ourselves was the Grand Canyon,
all the other ones were
just to meet Mythical Beast.
Yeah, so the Grand Canyon
was on the itinerary,
didn't happen, for reasons
I'll explain in a second.
Okay, so I'll get into
talking about the first stop
in just one moment.
First, we want to let you know about...
Rubik's Cube.
We invented this thing
called the Rubik's Cube,
and we thought it would be
cool to put our face on it.
No, we actually partnered
with the official Rubik's Cube company
and we created a Rhett and Link
mythical themed Rubik's Cube.
It's got our faces making
various faces on each face.
And it is solvable, but
just not by us right now,
that's why it's not currently solved.
It was solved.
But it looks great...
When it came in the mail.
When you buy one available
for a limited time,
it will come to you solved.
And then it's up to you to keep it solved.
Watch a YouTube video and
figure out how to solve it.
I've got to take this one home,
Lincoln knows how to solve Rubik's Cube.
So you know what, it's a good life skill.
If somebody here in the
office doesn't so he can...
It might be the only time
it comes in really handy.
And you mix it up and it
makes funny looking faces
that are a combination of
parts of my face and your face,
which is something I didn't anticipate.
Go to mythical.com,
get yourself the official Rubik's
Cube Collab with Mythical.
Okay, so based on the amount of hours
that we needed to be on the road,
I had an estimation of like,
we need to kind of hit like
an eight hours of driving per day or so
to kind of keep the pace up.
That's a lot.
I think for a leisurely pace,
you don't want to go much
more than five, if you're me.
I disagree, and that's
what I thought going in.
Your vehicle makes all the
difference in the world.
You know, when I took my solo trip
and I took my FJ, 2007 FJ
that's got big tires on it,
makes all kinds of noise
and it's just not a great
car for going long distances,
it's a great car for getting
over rocks and stuff,
I was absolutely mesmerized
at the size of the country.
And all I did was go into like Nevada
and then come back to California.
This is not an ad for a Ford Expedition,
but I was in like a new Ford Expedition
and something about smooth the ride was
made both Locke and I come
to the conclusion that
the United States isn't that big.
That's actually how we, we
were driving and be like...
It's sitting for eight
hours, it's a long time.
It wasn't that bad.
I mean, and I'll talk to you about
some other ways that we killed time.
Does it have a standing driving?
Yes, it's a standing desk situation.
The top goes up and you just sort of like.
That would be awesome, I mean...
RVs and buses should have that.
Sprinter vans should have that.
But then it's really hard to control
the gas and brake pedals while standing.
Right, that's probably why that's illegal.
But no, it didn't seem...
I was thinking...
I was preparing Locke...
I told Locke, I was like,
"Dude, mom and Shepherd
get back on the second,
you go back to school on the third,
as long as we're back before the second."
I set really, really low expectations
for how much we needed to move
and he was on board with that.
But we did have a place that
we wanted to get on night two,
which I'll explain in a second.
So first off, we wanted to go and stop
and stay the night in Nashville,
which is about seven
and a half, eight hours
from Fuquay-Varina, which
it was our point of origin.
Would you have thought that
all the way to Nashville, Tennessee,
just like seven or eight hours?
It's not just, it's pretty close.
I would've said, "Yes, that's pretty far."
Okay, yeah, I don't need to be asking you
how long things feel in
mileage and time though,
because things kind of
break down pretty quickly,
all I knew is that I wanted to stop,
We wanted to get out
on the road very early.
So the night before, Locke
wasn't staying with us,
he was staying with his cousins
and I was staying with Jesse's parents.
And I was like,
"Bro, I want you to just
bring your stuff over,
get your clothes washed."
And telling the 17-year-old
the things at 17-year-olds
need to know before they leave.
And I was just like, "Be ready."
He basically wasn't ready
until very late that night.
He went and hung out with his cousins,
but he was ready, we woke up,
no, well, right before, sorry.
Right before we went to bed...
I forgive you.
I'm asleep, It's 11:30, I'm
going to get up at like 6:30.
And we're gonna get on the road
at 7:00 AM, that's the plan.
He knocks on the door and wakes me up,
he was like, "Dad, I broke my crown."
So, Locke has a crown on
one of his front teeth
right here on the, whatever
that middle tooth, the incisor.
Okay.
And it had cracked right across the front.
Now, thankfully, my
father-in-law's a dentist
and we were staying at his
home and he was still up.
So he was like, "Okay,
I can fix it tomorrow."
And then he was like,
"Oh no, tomorrow, Sunday.
I won't have any assistants."
And then he's like, "Let me look at it."
He looks at it, he was like,
"Ah, you're fine until
you go to California."
At that point, I thought it was a crack.
It was going to be delayed, but it wasn't.
It didn't break off.
The facing of it had cracked off,
but it wasn't like exposing the tooth,
the root or anything
like that or the nerve.
So right off the bat, I was...
A little intrigued.
I was a little tense,
but we did end up leaving at 7:00 AM.
First stop was going to be in Asheville
because if you're going to Nashville,
you should stop at a
town that rhymes with it
before you get there,
that's a rule of thumb.
That the app told you that.
Yeah, and I knew definitively
that I wanted to eat
at Biscuit Head for lunch.
Okay, First stop Asheville, Biscuit Head.
Love these.
Filthy animals.
All day, this going to be good.
Biscuit Head, is a
restaurant in Asheville,
there's actually three locations,
I didn't know that.
This is a place that
specializes in biscuits.
Oh, my mouth is watering.
I like those big, tall stack,
fluffy buttermilk biscuits
with like bacon, egg, and cheese inside.
I'm going tell you
exactly what we ordered.
So, I was in large part,
building the trip around food, you know?
That's what I think
about most of the time.
So I was like,
we're not going to have
a bad meal on this trip.
We did, which I'll get to in a second,
but the plan was to not have
a bad meal on this trip.
It was about the destinations
and the sight seeing,
but it was also about the food
and we wanted to get
started on the right foot.
Now, I didn't know this,
but the whole Biscuit Head of it all,
apparently there's something
called like a cat head biscuit,
which is a Southern vernacular for
essentially biscuits and gravy.
Like when you take a biscuit
and you put stuff over the
top of it, I don't know,
it said something like that on the menu.
I was like, "Oh, I didn't know this,
I've been at this place several times."
But we got the filthy animal.
Which is a buttermilk
biscuit with fried chicken
on top of it, pimento cheese...
Oh God.
Bacon, scrambled eggs,
all smothered in gravy.
If you go there...
Smothered in gravy?
This is their specialty.
You've got to eat it with a fork?
You definitely gotta eat it with a fork.
This is what I recommend, that
you get to filthy the animal.
Everything's good though.
So Locke's...
Keep the change.
Already having a great time, you know?
We're spending a lot of
time listening to music.
I'll talk about a little
bit about some artists
that I helped him discover along the way,
but we're having a good time
and we were just very sort of like,
"Man, we got here real fast."
It feels like we just got
to Asheville real fast.
We eat, but like, we
want to get to Nashville
because I'm like,
not only are we going to
Nashville to get some hot chicken,
but I want to show him downtown Nashville
and show him the honky
tonks and all these stuff.
So on to Nashville,
which we ended up arriving
in Nashville at like 3:30 PM.
Oh, perfect.
We got there with plenty of time to spare.
Okay, it's official stop
number two, Nashville.
Don't look at yourself man,
look at the camera, man.
Now, you probably already know this
if you live outside of some
major areas like Los Angeles,
but COVID does not exist
in Nashville, Tennessee.
Apparently, has not made it
there, which is news to me.
I think they completely
eradicated it mentally.
Exactly, it turns out
that most of the country
has eradicated COVID mentally.
It does not exist in any of
the states after Nashville
until I got to like Phoenix.
And again, as I kind of outlined
a couple of podcasts ago,
as someone who's double vaxxed and boosted
and we were both double
vaxxed and boosted,
I was kind of like,
"Listen, I kinda got to just go along
with the flow of America here on this trip
or else I'm going to drive myself crazy."
So that's essentially what we did.
But we were going to do,
the main thing I wanted to do in Nashville
was to get hot chicken.
So we took a little tour of downtown,
stepped inside honky-tonk where the...
I go into the places where...
First of all, it's a
little bit mind blowing
if you've never been there,
for Locke it was really mind blowing
to just walk up and down this street
and literally every single
restaurant has got a person,
a band playing music, right?
Yeah, including Taco Bell, seriously.
Now, a lot of it is very bad.
I would say the majority of the music
that I heard coming out of
those places is pretty bad.
I'm not a huge fan of
modern country in general.
It gets better the later you stay.
But you go to a place where there's guys,
somebody's got gray hair and you're like,
"That's a good sign."
There's a dude who's playing a pedal steel
who looks like this may
be his last time ever
playing the pedal steel or
he may die while on stage.
Yeah.
And also there's hardly
anybody in there watching
except some other old people.
I saw that place and I was like,
"This is where we need to go."
We go inside, over the
course of like five songs
they played three Merle Haggard songs.
Do you remember which one it was?
I can't remember the place
that was our favorite
from when we played at the Ryman.
I don't remember the name
of the place, honestly.
It is a woman's name.
But it was towards the river
and pretty close to like
the Glen Campbell Museum
and a little road you go off
to get to the Johnny Cash Museum,
which I didn't go into.
We just kind of took a
picture for Shepherd...
And they would let Locke
in there, under age?
Dude, there's no rules, man.
Okay.
In fact the waitress offered him a beer.
I mean, he doesn't look 17, he looks...
No.
And I was like, "Ah, let's not do that."
So we did that but then it
was all about the hot chicken.
Yeah, I'm curious, where did you go?
So my experience, the
first time I ever had
authentic Nashville hot chicken,
which a lot of people are like,
"You talking about spicy chicken?"
Hopefully, if you've watched
Good Mythical Morning,
you know the hot chicken
is not spicy chicken.
It is his own category,
it's not like the spicy chicken sandwich
you get at McDonald's, okay?
This is a very specific
recipe and it's very good
and it's one of my favorite things.
The breading is very red.
Yeah, it has a lot of spice
mixed into the breading
and then it's got like
a coating of like dry,
but also a little bit wet,
you've got to just have it.
So the best I've ever had
is Hattie B's in Nashville
but I had even heard that that Hattie B's
was not the originator of hot chicken.
We were told, when we went there,
that Bolton's Hot Chicken
and Fish was the originator
and we went there and
it was very, very good.
Very down-home.
But it turns out that
that's also not true.
Bolton's is not the first person to do it.
The first place to do it
is Prince's Hot Chicken.
I never even heard of
Prince's Hot Chicken,
but I'm telling...
I told you about Prince's Hot Chicken.
I thought you told me about Bolton's.
No, no, no, when I took the kids
to the wedding in Nashville
last year, we went to Prince's.
Did you go to the one in Assembly Hall
or did you go to the original location?
It was on, I think the original
location after the fire,
not the original, original,
it was in a strip mall.
We waited way too long for it.
Well, I blocked that out of my mind
and I probably about to tell you something
that you already know,
but just let me tell you.
So Assembly Hall is like
sort of like a food court
on steroids, a mall.
Oh, near downtown?
Right across the street from the Ryman.
Yeah.
That's where you went?
There's a Prince's there?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's a Hattie B's there.
It's new, there wasn't when you went
There wasn't when I went.
Okay, all right, so...
But I went to the Hattie B's there,
which it must be right in the same place.
The Prince's is upstairs
in the food court area,
Hattie B's is down in the outdoor mall.
So, you went for Prince's.
Okay, Locke and I got into
this discussion and I was like,
"Listen, I'm going to tell you right now,
I've never had better hot
chicken than Hattie B's,
but I've also never had Prince's
and everyone is saying that
princess is the original place."
And then we go online and we're looking at
all these lists of the places
that you should have hot chicken
and list after list is like,
"Go to Prince's Hot for the original.
Everyone is just trying to
imitate that, it's true."
So I was like, "Well, okay,
I mean, it's not going to be
a disappointing experience.
I mean, it may not be
as good as Hattie B's,
side-by-side comparison or whatever."
But the thing that
Locke said, he was like,
"Dad, but there's a lot of
people in line at Hattie B's
and there's not a lot of
people in line at Prince's.
And I was like, "well,
that's just because it's like
it's upstairs in this place
and Hattie B's is a better location."
But I was also like,
"Okay, you just tell me
which one you want to do."
And he was like, "I think
we should go to the place
that has more people at it."
And I was like, "But
what about the original?"
I take full responsibility for this
because I talked him
into going to Prince's.
Dad said, "Do you want to get the best
or do you want to get the original?"
I said, "Let's get the best."
He's like, "We've got
to get the original."
We got it, it pretty shit.
It wasn't bad.
It was bad.
I can't believe it, I did the same thing.
But you got to rectify it.
Yeah, I went to Hattie B's the next day.
Well, I wasn't able to do
that because I had to leave.
Let me just tell you right now.
Once I got up there and
we put our order in,
and by the way, we also got T-shirts
that said Prince's Hot Chicken
because I'm working a T-shirt
and I've got a hat at Biscuit Head,
we're getting memorabilia
all over the place,
this is just what the
road trip's all about.
It's a good idea.
So, we order a couple of
medium hot chicken sandwiches,
so typically medium is like super hot,
if you have any experience
with hot chicken.
The hot it's like harder
than anyone can handle
and there's two levels above that
and it's just kind of like comical
to even think about typically.
Yeah.
So, I noticed that there's
a lot of people in line.
There's a lot of people waiting,
not only people in line,
but a lot of people waiting.
And then at that point
is when I go to the specific Yelp reviews,
not for Prince's, but for
this Prince's location,
which is like not in
the original location,
it's like the mall location,
for lack of a better word.
Yeah, it's a tourist trap downtown.
And I begin to get a sinking feeling
because people are like,
"This place is so poorly managed.
It's not going to be
representative of hot chicken.
It's just a piece of
chicken with some sauce,
kind of dollops on it."
And then I'm there
saying, these people are,
"There's no way it's that bad."
There's no way a place
that has this reputation
is letting this happen.
I mean, it's not going to be bad,
I mean, the worst,
it's just going to be a
good fried chicken sandwich.
It was the most disappointing
culinary experience
I've ever had in my entire life.
Man, I wish you would
have gone just downstairs
to the Hattie B's right afterwards.
Well, the line at Hattie B's...
Well, remember what I told you
because it was so good.
I wasn't sure that you Prince's.
It's touristy.
I mean, everything in
that area is for tourists,
but Hattie B's, they've
optimized the tourist experience
with some of the things that they offer.
Well, but it's also, it's just good.
It's so good.
It's good and it's consistent.
And so lesson learned
for me, first of all,
I had to apologize profusely to Locke,
we ended up getting like some
Jennie's ice cream after.
I almost was like, "Let's just
go and get right back in line
and just get Hattie B's."
But that line was probably an hour long
and we kind of were tired
and wanted to go to bed.
But, I can't speak for the
original Prince's location
but if the Prince's enterprise is allowing
any location to be as horrible
as the one in Assembly
Hall, then I'm never going.
I will never go, you lost your opportunity
to gain me as a fan.
Hattie B's is amazing, and
Bolton's is really good,
but Hattie B's is the standard.
You shouldn't go to the
place that created it,
you should go to the
place that perfected it,
and they have perfected it.
At least for tourists, I totally agree.
By the way, there's a hip-hop
theme pizza restaurant
right across the way from
it in that same thoroughfare
and I recommend that place too.
Well, if I had to spent multiple days.
I mean, next time I come through
I know what I'm doing.
They've got cinnamon rolls.
We stayed at the Graduate
Hotel on Music Row,
I don't know if you know about this place,
but it's basically a
country music themed hotel
that has some awesome decor
and like pictures of
Dolly Parton in the lobby.
Oh, that's cool.
And your key, cards for
getting in and out of your room
are like student IDs, I had
like Waylon Jennings' student ID
and Johnny Cash's student ID.
It's like what you have is
your key to open your door.
Student ID.
It is made up, it's not real.
I don't think they ever had student IDs.
Emmylou Harris, a portrait
of her was over my bed
and I can't remember who was
Locke's bed, I've got pictures,
you're probably seeing them at this point.
But that was a fun experience.
Also, shout out to the front desk,
they're Mythical Beast at the Graduate,
at least those that I
interacted with that night.
But we got on the next morning.
Did you get a chocolate on your pillow,
a night chocolate?
They don't do that, it's
not a country music thing.
I mean, for you.
So next day we're up
and the goal is to get
to Chester, Arkansas.
Never heard of it.
No reason to have heard of it until today.
Hopefully, I'm going to give
you a reason to hear about it.
But we were going to go through Memphis.
So we knew we were
going to stop in Memphis
and again, I'm thinking about two things.
I'm thinking about-
Ribs and ribs.
I'm thinking about stopping
at Central Barbecue,
which has the best ribs we've ever had.
If you remember the...
I'm crying, man.
On Memphis trip where we decided
on what the best ribs were
and it was clearly Central Barbecue?
We wanted to stop there
but the downtown location
is directly across the street
from the Civil Rights Museum,
which is at the Lorraine
Hotel, which is where
MLK was shot and killed.
And I've never been in
there and I was like,
"This'll be a cool thing
for father and son to do."
We get to have this incredible meal
and then we get essentially
some sobering US history
in the middle of our trip,
but it turns out that the
Central Barbecue location
was closed at that for
some reason, it was closed.
And I was like, well, I've
got my heart set on this
so I had to drive 15 minutes
to the original Central Barbecue location,
which is on Central Avenue,
I didn't know about this.
So, now I've seen the other one,
it's a lot like the second one.
So, you were at the MLK Museum,
but since Central Barbecue was closed
you didn't go in the museum.
Well, it was lunchtime,
we were super hungry.
You had get to Central Barbecue.
And we wanted to spend a
couple of hours at the museum,
I wasn't about to go
in there, we were also,
we weren't eating breakfast,
we were like getting a
coffee when we woke up
and it was like, we're
going to, and we eat lunch.
I've been doing like an
intermittent fasting thing
and Locke is amenable
to pretty much anything
so that's what we decided to do.
It was also, you can kind of
get on the road and just go.
So go to the original
Central Barbecue location.
I got to say, I love Central Barbecue,
but for me, the thing
that shines is the ribs
and everything else is kinda
just like good barbecue,
but not great barbecue.
I don't remember if that
was your experience,
if you remember.
We were already so full when we got
the spread from Central
Barbecue when we went there.
We were on a rib mission.
So, did the ribs hold true?
The ribs are so good.
Great, okay.
I got ribs, pulled pork
and I ordered chicken,
I thought I was ordering
the smoked chicken,
but they gave me the shredded chicken,
like the pulled chicken,
it is a little dry.
And again, I think I said that
the rendezvous beans were better,
I got beans and they're not bad,
but it's really, Just get the ribs.
If you're a rib person, get the ribs.
But going back to the Civil Rights Museum,
which, again...
So, you did go back to
the Civil Rights Museum?
Oh yeah,
That's what I was asking.
You seemed like you were just like,
I have to make a choice and
it's going to be for ribs.
No, no, no, I'm saying that...
Okay, so you went back.
we wanted to eat at Central Barbecue
and then we were going go
back to Civil Rights Museum.
Oh, I didn't know you went back.
I mean, it's still in the same town.
I'm driving across the country,
15 minutes is not going to
be that big a difference.
You're on an expedition.
So, we go to the museum
and, listen, I mean,
you can imagine the sort of
intensity of the experience
of the Civil Rights Museum,
but I can't really say
anything to communicate that.
I just got to tell you
if you're in Memphis,
you should go to it, right?
And I think that the story of the hotel
and how after he was
killed there on the balcony
the story of the thing
falling into disrepair
and then like local
leaders coming together
and saying, "We wanna save this hotel."
And then they literally
built the museum around it
and inside of it, but kept
the two rooms right there,
the one that he stayed
in and the one that,
I think they had a meeting in,
or the one he was shot in front
of, they kept them intact.
And then they've added
some things of like,
this is what would have been on the table
and here's like the
ashtray with cigarettes
that they may have been smoking and stuff,
it's just a really well done museum
that has so much information.
I actually felt bad because
there's so much information
to read and to digest
and there's so many cool
things to watch and experience
as you go through,
but when you're on a road
trip and you're kind of like,
we have to get to Chester,
for reasons I'll get to in a second,
so we actually only did like
two thirds of the museum.
There's a whole other side,
which kind of goes underground
and I think it goes up to the place
where the shot was fired
or gets close to it.
I didn't go in, so I'm
not sure, I'm speculating.
But definitely recommend
that, and it was very,
just seeing the spot, hearing the story
and then standing up there right
next to where he was shot is just like,
it's a sobering experience for anyone.
But then on to Chester, Arkansas.
So that was what was kind of driving us
to get to Nashville then to Memphis,
then the Chester to spend the night.
So we talked a lot about Lance
and Lacey of Beard and Lady,
some really good friends
of mine and of ours.
Bearded lady makes all the
the mythical grooming products
and also helped us kind of come
up with the idea originally
for beard oil and lip
balm and all that stuff.
Well, Lacey is from this area of Arkansas,
which is right off of 40
as you're coming through
because most of our trip was on 40.
I mean, they're like literally
like 15 minutes from 40.
So as soon as I'm mapping
through it, I'm like,
"Hold on, this goes
right through Arkansas."
And then I was like,
"This is like right next to
where they've got this hotel."
So they have bought this historic
100-year-old hotel in Chester,
which is a very teeny,
tiny town and they had...
They built a museum around it?
No, it's not like the
museum, they have restored it
and it's called the Beard and Lady Inn,
and it has three components.
Number one, it's a hotel with 11 rooms,
so it's kind of like a boutique hotel.
I'll tell you about the rooms in a second,
it also has a restaurant
that serves local Arkansas
wild game and stuff.
By the time this goes out
and you're listening to this,
it will be, basically they're opening up
the restaurant as we speak.
All this information is
at beardandladyinn.com,
but there's also a Mark and Tile.
So like a store where they
sell mythical products,
but also a bunch of other
stuff from like local vendors.
If you're like a Northwest Arkansas person
and you've got something cool to sell,
like there there's so much room
in this incredible facility
they've set up that you can...
And they're doing all
kinds of stuff there.
I mean, I highly recommend
it if you're coming through,
because it's definitely the
coolest place that we stayed.
Even cooler than Graduate,
just because of the history of this place.
And also it's haunted.
Is it?
Yeah, so it has a reputation,
in fact, as they were,
they bought this thing a couple years ago
and then they slowly restored it
and they said that locals
would come by and be like,
"You seen a ghost yet?"
Basically, this place is
notorious for being haunted.
So, I think it also be a destination
for paranormal seeking people.
Doesn't that play into the theme?
Yeah, so the theme of the rooms
it's either fear of something
or it's just a general theme
about a life experience.
But it's kind of funny in that,
I stayed in the fear of
commitment room, right?
And so Lacey's family
history goes way, way back
in that area and her grandparents
were incredible collectors
or archivers of their family
history and pictures and stuff
and so they've got these pictures
in that room that I stayed in.
There's all these pictures
of her grandparents
and relatives in there, wedding portraits
and pictures of them together
throughout the years.
All this old, like 10 type old school,
black and white photography,
and everything's...
Basically, it tells a story of commitment.
Yeah, so it's like,
"Okay, if you've got fear of commitments,
let's see all these people around you
that are committed to one another."
Interestingly, one of the rooms,
which I think it might be fear of death,
you can go on the website
and see all the rooms,
but her great-grandparents
are the only people known on record,
at least on record at the
time, to request a dual coffin.
What?
They died within hours of each other
and the dual coffin was made for them.
And there's pictures of them
in the coffin, all in the room.
What?
It's incredible.
So is it, okay, first of all,
how did they die so closely?
Because I guess the first
thing I thought was,
okay, one of them dies, you bury them
then you've got to dig them up
and throw the other person in there?
Yeah, I think it was...
They were counting on
dying at the same time?
I think that the circumstances led to,
she died or he, one of them died first,
and the other one knew that
they were about to die.
I can't remember,
the story of the same disease or whatever.
Throw us in the same coffin.
I think it was like a last
minute request like that
and they totally did it, it was crazy.
Was it a wider coffin?
Yeah, it's shaped like a square.
It's like a square coffin.
What?
Yeah and there's pictures of them in it.
Dead bodies in it?
Yeah, but you don't have
to stay in that room,
it's all about your level of comfort.
And there's one room that is
known as, the Haunted Room.
First of all, the whole place
is potentially haunted, right?
But there's one room that
is right above the place
where a guy once like froze
to death in this little,
I think this saloon
that was attached to it.
Again, all these stories in
more detail are on the website,
but I didn't stay in
that room, but we walked,
they're just opening and so
there was one other couple
that was staying there that night
and then it was me and Locke
and we stayed in enjoining rooms.
Lance and Lacey's history of
traveling multiple
times to the Middle East
over the 20's and 30's
and they've got all these like artifacts
and like a camel saddle
and all this stuff,
that was connected to my room.
So the Middle East room, which
is not a fear of anything,
it's just a Middle East theme room,
and then I was in the
fear of commitment room,
and then there's a
bathroom attached to that
and so we were kind of
had enjoining rooms.
Okay.
But it's really hard for
me to convey how cool
and unusual of a space it is
and the thing that they're trying to do
because it's on the railroad
and they're currently basically lobbying
to get it added as a stop
so you can be in one of
the major city centers
that's close by north and
south and you can take a train
and it will let you off.
And they've also bought a church,
this 100-year-old church
in a nearby place that,
the whole idea is that people,
and I think this is already,
they've had a couple of wedding parties,
because it's a really cool
thing to run the whole hotel
and have an event.
And they bought this church
and the idea is that in the future people
will get married at this venue,
And then dine in the hotel.
and then go to the hotel.
And again, if you're into
paranormal stuff, it's great.
If you're not, there's plenty of options
and plenty of rooms to
stay in that are not,
but it was one of the
coolest stops that we made.
And then it kind of took us
on a tour of the family land
and some other stuff the next morning
and we got to see some
of Northwest Arkansas,
which is a special place, special place.
Special place, huh? Hilly?
Yeah, actually it's pretty mountainous.
I would call it,
it feels like you're in the
North Carolina mountains.
And I mean, essentially I think
it's a different mountain range.
because it's like the Ozarks.
But it has that feel of
like very wooded mountains
that you just feel like you get lost
and lots of lakes and stuff.
Lots of streams and rivers.
That's cool.
But I didn't see...
That would be night two.
Yeah, I didn't see anything.
No ghosts?
I didn't see any ghosts
and I was very open to it.
And I was like standing in there at night,
sort of staring into the mirror
waiting for things to happen.
I was embracing it, I was like,
if something's going to happen,
I want to be here for it
but the ghosts left me alone.
Again, beardandladyinn.com.
That's not my rec, but it is a rec,
you should go and check it out.
Next stop, Oklahoma City.
Already in Oklahoma.
I mean, you drive for two days
and you're in Oklahoma, basically.
See, the country is not that big, Link.
Oklahoma City, I don't
think I've ever been there.
I had been in Oklahoma City,
well, you have, because you
went through on 40 with me.
Well, we went through it,
but I don't think we stopped.
We may have just stopped.
I think you've been as
a basketball player,
I remember this.
Yeah, the AAU National
Championship in 1996
was in Oklahoma City
and my team went to play
in the National Championship.
Did you lose?
We didn't win.
Okay, you forfeited.
What other option is there?
No, we placed like 12th in the country.
You weren't personally in
the National Championship?
It was all the best AAU
teams in the nation.
You were in the tournament,
but not in the...
So, almost top 10, we're
pretty good, we're pretty good.
Okay, you're in the top 10.
One thing I remember
when you came back was,
I think that's when you told me
that you were sleeping in bunk
beds and that your roommates,
your teammates and roommates
would bring back girls
to sleep in there or do something
precisely in their bunk beds.
It wasn't bunk beds,
it was like a split level condominium
and so we were all
sleeping in like pull-out,
there was bedrooms, but there
was also a pull-out couches.
And me and a guy were sleeping
on a pullout bed together
upstairs in the loft
but then there were two
of our other teammates
who were downstairs in another bed
in the middle of the living room
and they were bringing girls into that bed
and proceeding to make love to them.
And there were lots of open,
the first time I'd actually
like been in a room
with someone else making love.
There were four of them in one bed?
No, think the one guy would be like,
"I'm going to go do something else
while you bring your girl
in here and make love
and then we'll switch."
I heard two different female
sounds in different times.
Yeah, but you stayed put.
I wasn't really planning
on talking about this,
but thanks for bringing it up.
That, yes, that is my
previous Oklahoma City story.
Okay, top that.
But of course, what I'm interested in,
the first thing I'm interested in is food.
I got what I came for.
The first thing I'm interested in is food
and we actually didn't quite get there
at the right time for a meal
but the place that I wanted to eat...
At your age, yeah,
munch is in food then...
Well, there's two things,
the first thing was food and...
Sex, talk about sex.
Okay, there's a restaurant
that I think is called 39,
which is at the First Nations Museum.
So there's this incredible
Native American museum
that's going up in Oklahoma.
Of course, that was a lot of
the Native American territory
and reservations and stuff
and COVID has like severely dampened
the schedule for this thing
but you can see it as
you're going by on 40,
this incredible structure that's going up,
but it just wasn't open yet.
It's not open yet, okay.
But there's a restaurant
that's going to be there
that it made it seem like it was open.
It's called 39 because
there's like 39 tribes
that are local to the
state or to the region
and there was going to be food
from each one of those tribes on the menu
and I was like, "This
would be super cool."
But it wasn't clear
that it wasn't open yet
I think it opened sometime this year.
And the way I figured out some of this
is through Atlas Obscura.
Not all of this was on roadtrippers.com
so I had the roadtrippers.com up,
but then I would like
pull up Oklahoma City
on Atlas Obscura, which is like a weird...
A website that shows interesting...
Weird stuff.
And a weird things to
do, weird things to see,
weird things that exist that
you can't have access to,
but also weird things to
eat, like weird restaurants.
Huh? You got pay for that?
No, that's all free.
Oh, that's free, I like that.
But there was this thing called
the Oklahoma City Underground,
which they made seem cool.
Okay.
And this is essentially,
okay, I love underground stuff,
I've established this.
I wrote a whole book about it,
and I've always been obsessed with
the underneath cities kind of thing
and so I was thinking
that this was going to be
something like the Parisian
Catacombs or something,
but it's Oklahoma City,
I should have changed my expectations.
Yeah, maybe it's there's
a subway, and like a...
All it is...
A hardware store?
Is, the downtown Oklahoma
City has been connected
via pathways that are
underneath the ground.
Let's call those tunnels.
Tunnels.
Let's call them underground walkways
because you get too excited about tunnels.
They feel like hallways though.
And it was like, oh, it's home
to art galleries and stuff
what they mean by that is
that there's a few places
where all of a sudden there'll
be pictures on the wall
and there'll be like purple lighting
or red lighting or yellow lighting.
It's all lit but then
there's these signs that say,
progress energy building,
so-and-so government building.
It's just like buildings that
I'm not interested in going to
and probably wouldn't have access to
connected via underground....
You know what?
It reminds me of like the
suspended walkways in Minneapolis.
It's the same exact principle.
It was like above ground, the sky walks,
so that you didn't have
to be out in the weather.
Yeah, it's similar to that
and maybe it's because it's so hot.
But it seemed like a maze
and it wasn't really a cool place
because it's kind of cramped.
It's exactly the same thing
and I actually think
there are some sky walks
that are part of it once you get
to some of the buildings
that are close together.
All I can say is it's not very cool.
Okay.
I think we did take a dump in
one of the bathrooms there.
Skip that one there.
It's super isolated and
there was nobody around.
You were picturing like
catacombs, I'm sorry, man.
Well, I wasn't picturing catacombs,
I was picturing that this was something
that existed in the past
and had been commandeered
for these purposes versus
something that was built
relatively recently as
the way that it feels.
It feels too sterile and
just not cool enough.
So we kind of walked
probably like half a mile
and realized it was all the
same and walked back out.
And that was it, that
was Oklahoma City for us.
Oklahoma city proved
to be a disappointment.
My first trip back when I
listened to people have sex
was definitely a better trip.
So you didn't top it,
but let's just move on.
On to Amarillo. and of course,
when you're going into Amarillo,
this is the perfect opportunity
to introduce your son
to the music of George Strait.
Famously known for Amarillo by Morning
and I think more, number one country hits
than any country artists.
That sounds right to me.
Were you coming up from San Antonio?
No, we were coming from
the east of Oklahoma City.
Was everything that you
got, just what you got on?
No, we had a whole truck full of things.
You didn't have a dime
but what you had was mine?
None of the song applied to us.
In fact, we weren't trying
to get there by morning,
we were trying to get there to sleep.
What a good song though, did you play it?
Oh, we played that and
then proceeded to play,
basically, you just go to
Spotify and you just play
the most popular stuff from George Strait
and you just remember like,
"Oh yeah, that one and that one."
And it's not like my favorite
country music of all time,
but you immediately understand
why he had so many number one hits
because first of all,
he had great songwriters
and he was a great, great deliverer of...
♪ Baby blue ♪
Did you hear that one?
Yeah, we went through a bunch of them.
Yeah, Christie got me the
George Strait CD box set
when we were dating and that,
I mean, that was special.
There's a lot of romance in there.
Yeah, his most popular
songs are the love songs.
Even the whole string to the '90s,
like Check Yes or No and all that stuff,
it gets a little cheesy.
When I go back and listen to it now...
And the '80s is my sweet spot.
I wasn't to differentiate as a younging
I wasn't able to differentiate
between how good like
Amarillo by Morning was
compared to Check Yes or No,
you know what I mean?
I'm sure that Check Yes or No
was preferred in the '90s,
but yeah, I liked that old sound and we...
The chair, did you play The Chair for him?
Oh yeah, yeah.
You didn't tell him ahead of time?
The Chair, I had played for him before,
but not really as an
introduction to George Strait
and all his music.
It was more just like,
"Hey, this is one of the
classic country songs."
Was he into it?
He loved it, he loved it.
And then he would do things like,
he would take a picture of us
and put it on his Instagram
and then Amarillo in Morning
would be like, on his story,
would be like the music that
was playing or whatever.
Okay, okay.
Locke was having the time of his life
being introduced to some,
he knows pretty much all the
music that I've listened to,
but I was digging a little
bit deeper on this trip.
Digging a lot deeper,
that's a Diamond Rio.
That's a different...
Well, hang on for Diamond Rio.
So one of the things
that Locke wanted to do,
I was like, "Okay, we're
going to get to Amarillo
and we're gonna spend the night
and then there's something
we're going to see
in the morning in Amarillo."
But he was like, "Okay,
we're coming into Texas.
This is like Friday Night, Lights dad.
We've got to go to an ice cream place."
He wanted to do sit down
at an ice cream place
like they do on a Friday Night Lights.
Okay, tasty frees time?
Yeah, we go to this burger place
and that's when he's like,
and first of all, I can't
remember the name of the place,
but it's the number one
rated restaurant in Amarillo,
according to Yelp.
And it's like a hole in
the wall burger place
that also does rib-eyes
and it wasn't great.
It just wasn't great.
I've had a lot of really good burgers,
and people in on Yelp were like,
"This is the best burger I ever had."
Well, I feel sorry for you
because there's much better burgers.
But then we saw this place
pretty close by called Braum's.
I don't know if you've ever,
this is a chain in Texas that Kikos...
B-R-A-H-M?
B-R-A-U-M'S, and it has
like ice cream cone on it.
So I was like, "Oh, an ice
cream place, it's open."
We go in there.
It's not just an ice cream place,
it is a place that serves like
burgers and stuff like that,
milkshakes, but it also has ice cream.
So it's got a bunch of places to sit
and it is a convenience store.
All open together,
it's like a dairy themed
convenience store.
With like milk and yogurt and stuff.
Gas station?
Not a gas station, it is a restaurant.
I've never been in a
place like this in my life
where you've got the restaurant over here
and the convenience store over here
and it's all open,
there's no dividers, and
there's like a cashier up there
with a menu in the ice cream.
Sounds like a truck stop to me.
It was unlike anything I've ever,
it was not any of those
things you're saying.
And this is the chain?
Yes, very popular chain.
And shout out to the staff
of the Braum's and Amarillo,
many of whom are Mythical Beasts.
Did they give you a chocolate?
Well, I ordered my food.
I am not looking for the freebies
Got to get those perks.
Locke wanted a banana split.
Again, he was like in
this Friday Night Lights,
he's like, he can get a banana..
So he got the banana split.
And first of all, I was not hungry at all,
but I got like a sundae
and ate the whole thing.
Of course you did.
I came to regret that the next day.
But then, at this point,
we're using hotel tonight
and like staying at
the holiday Inn that's available.
Last minute because I wasn't exactly sure
whether we would make it.
That night was not a
destination hotel, right?
But we wake up in the morning
and I don't know if you remember this,
we stopped there before,
but right outside of Amarillo
is the Cadillac Ranch,
which again is basically a farmer
who decided that he was
gonna just plant Cadillacs.
I guess he was trying
to grow Cadillac trees.
Oh, I've not been there,
but I've seen potoes.
You've seen potoes?
It's weird that we didn't stop there
because we literally drove past it.
It's like I've read the word potoes
and I've never heard it before.
How do you say potoes?
So we stopped and got some
potoes at the Cadillac Ranch.
It was so cold that morning,
but literally all it
is is like a corn field
or the crops were not currently
planted and just Cadillacs.
And of course...
No entry fee?
No entry fee and you can paint on them.
Oh, you can?
There's a bunch of spray paint bottles
and people are constantly tagging them
to the point they're like,
the way that the pain
is dripping off of them.
It's created a whole new
entity of a painted Cadillac.
Very cool, great photo up or potoe up.
We did that, but the thing
we were trying to get to
that day was Albuquerque.
How did you get to New Mexico?
Again, I always have
like a food thing in mind
and then I've got like a
sight seeing thing in mind.
The food thing that I had in mind
was getting some of that New Mexican,
like green chili-type food,
which we stopped at a place,
I can't remember the name
of it, but it was good.
We got like the authentic
New Mexican cuisine,
which is different than
just regular Mexican food.
There's an emphasis on
the green chili sauce.
But of course, Albuquerque
is known as the place
where Breaking Bad was filmed,
which is one of my
favorite shows of all time
and one of Locke's
favorite shows of all time.
We didn't watch it concurrently
because I watched it a long time ago
then he watched it on his
own like two years ago.
So, there are multiple...
They still film it there.
They filmed, any exterior scene
in Breaking Bad is in Albuquerque.
The carwash, Walter White's
house, Jesse's house.
Yeah, I remember the house.
I guess the house was just like,
I didn't know if it was a cheat,
they shot there a lot, I guess.
Lots of outside shots,
places where they got
in fights on the road.
So I think they either they shot,
they shot a lot of it in Albuquerque.
Like a lot of it.
Not just exterior locations,
there's lots of things going on there.
So, were are you going to
do like a driving tour?
Yeah, so there's multiple sites
that have put together the
different stops and like,
okay, this part of town
you can see these things,
this part of town you
can see these things.
Of course, the thing that we
were most excited about was,
Walter and Skyler's house, the main house.
Yeah.
Now, I kind of heard that,
because none of this is official
and this is just somebody's
private residence
that the people who live there
are not exactly thrilled about this.
And in fact, in the thing
that I looked up, it said,
"The people who live here are not happy
about the fact that they
own this historic house.
And they kind of want
you to take your pictures
from across the street
and get out of there."
So I was like, "Oh, okay, that's fine.
I'll just take my picture
from across the street
and get out of there."
Just annoy the neighbors by
being in front of their house.
Well, I mean, how annoying is it
for somebody to stop for a second?
If there's a constant stream, I get it.
Well, let me tell you,
saying that they're not pleased with it
or they don't think it is ideal
is the understatement of the year, okay?
We pull up to the house.
The first thing I noticed...
It's in the neighborhood, right?
It's in a neighborhood,
it's just like a suburb.
There is a fence that has
been erected around the house
that completely changes the look of it
and changes the view somewhat.
Chain like fence?
There's a picture, I can't remember.
It's not a chain-link kind of thing,
but you can kind of see through it,
but it doesn't look the same.
And then there's multiple
signs on the fence
and on the house that says,
this is a private residence,
take your pictures from
across the street and move on
or something like that.
So, we park across the
street and then we get out.
And then I see that there is an older lady
who comes out of the front door
Of the house?
of the house.
And she just looks at me,
and this woman looks mad
and she just stands there
looking at me like this.
Crosses her arms, sets up,
and just makes eye contact with me.
And I'm thinking like, okay,
and I'm like, I've got to say something.
I'm like, "Hey, how you doing?
You mind if we get a picture?"
And she said, "I do mind,
this is a private residence.
It has always been a private residence.
And it will always be
a private residence."
What, all these years later,
the owner is having a
face-to-face interaction
with you about it and it's this heated
after all of this time?
Her, I don't know when she
bought the house pre or post,
but the thing is, listen, at that point
I felt so sorry for her
and the level of bitterness
that is consuming her and her life
that I was like, "Okay, no problem."
And instead of like being an asshole,
and like taking a picture
or talking back to her,
which I'm sure a lot of people do,
I was just like, "Okay."
And we got back in the
car and Locke was like,
"Dad, I told you that they didn't like."
I was like, "You didn't tell me
that it was this serious of a thing."
He was like, "No, no, Micah,
My nephew and his cousin.
"Micah said, she really hates it."
I was like, "You didn't tell me that."
Your nephews had visited it?
No, they just knew
because Locke said that
we were going to do it
and they like were talking,
looked it up online.
And I was just like,
man, I couldn't wrap my
mind around the like,
did this woman buy this house
and then let them film there for a fee,
never expecting that it would become
this huge cultural phenomenon
and now she just doesn't sell the house
or did she buy the house after the fact
and didn't fully know how popular it was?
I mean, all these years later,
I mean, I'm sure every year that passes
less and less people visit.
But as we were leaving, there
was another person coming in.
There was?
Oh yeah, it is a constant
stream of traffic.
So I can only imagine
how the neighbors feel.
I don't feel great about
the fact that we did it,
but we were not intrusive.
And if she hadn't said anything,
we would just gotten out of the car
in the middle of the road,
taken a picture and just gone on.
An annoyance, yes,
so, I don't really know what the way,
if you're going to be annoyed by it
I think you have to sell the house
to someone who would think it was cool
or like Vince Gilligan
should just buy the house
from this woman and let people take
all the pictures they want,
I don't know, I don't
know what the solution is.
Yeah, you've ruined this
person's life unintentionally
and then they can't sell it at a price
because of what it is that
they would need to sell it for,
so they just live there.
Well, that's the thing,
Locke was like, "Wouldn't
the value go up?"
I was like, "No, think about it,
whenever the number of
people who are interested
in a place goes down,
more people would be
turned off by the idea
of buying a landmark that
people would come to.
So if you lower the amount of people
who are demanding of the house,
then the price of the house
goes down, ironically."
So Lance and Lacey should buy it.
and turn it into an Airbnb.
To a hotel.
So, I don't know what the history is,
but I felt bad about it.
Well, the rest of the neighborhood
probably won't let them
turn it into an Airbnb,
but that's what should have happened.
It should be a freaking,
put Lance and Lacey on it.
But that was just the
beginning of the tour,
because the next stop was the carwash,
which I can't remember the name
of the carwash in the show,
but this is where the carwash
that Walt buys to launder the money.
And it is still intact and
still functioning as a carwash.
And it's just very iconic shape.
So, we pull up to the carwash
and there's a giant open
parking lot right next to it,
which makes it easy to kind of
stop and just get a picture.
And like the guys watching the cars
kind of look at you like,
"Yeah, this happens all day every day."
But it's the place of business.
Yeah, it's not a big deal.
They don't care probably.
There's a group of people
who had just taken pictures
in front of the carwash
who were also on the self-guided tour,
they're getting back into their car
and then Locke and I take a picture
and like take a little video out there
and then we see them get
back out of their car
and there's a girl who
has this look on her face.
I'm like this, "She must
be a giant Breaking Bad fan
because she's coming back for a more."
It turns out that she was
a huge Mythical Beast,
and it was crazy, she...
Did you tell her, "Don't
go to Walt's house."
I did, I said, we just had
an interaction with a lady,
because they had not been there yet,
it was their next stop.
I don't know if they went, but yeah.
So I can't remember your name.
You tweeted at me after the fact,
and I'm sorry, I can't remember your name,
but you know who you are.
We got some pictures out
in front of the carwash,
and then we continued on to...
They should give you a chocolate.
Jesse Pinkman's house,
which apparently they're not
too keen on it, but they weren't there
and there's no signs.
And again, as we stopped to take a picture
another father and son in another car
were stopping as we left.
It's a constant stream
because Breaking Bad
is such an iconic show,
and so many points of reference for it.
I mean, we've been to
the Brady Bunch house
and Toluca Lake...
Well, in LA there's
houses all over the place
that you can go.
Like, the Jamie Lee Curtis'
Halloween house, Brady took me there.
And they have a little sign
that says take your picture,
but keep your distance.
Yeah.
Actually, they had candy on their porch
and they were like,
"Feel free to take some
candy, take a picture,
and thank you for being nice about this."
Yeah, to me, it's like the
main difference is like,
if you live in New York City
and you live in the city,
well, there's all kinds of stuff
going on right outside
your front door constantly.
It's a different lifestyle
than what you would get
in suburban Albuquerque.
But that would be my
way of dealing with it,
would be like, "Hey, listen,
people are going to be
constantly coming to our house
and taking pictures, just to make sure
they can't see in the windows
and then if they come
by, we can greet them"
It's tough, it's tough man.
But, I didn't sign up for it.
I didn't let him film there
and I didn't buy the house.
Okay. So that was Albuquerque.
The next stop was supposed to be,
we were going to keep going
west and then go up north
to the Grand Canyon.
We were actually going
to go to Monument Valley
that very famous drive
in, I guess it's Arizona,
New Mexico or Arizona, but it's like,
you've seen it a million times.
One of the most iconic
drives in all of America.
Then there was a horseshoe.
Ben, which is that crazy
horse you've seen on Instagram
1000 times and then the Grand Canyon.
But the winter weather was
really rolling in to the tune of,
it was going to be a high of like 18°
at the Grand Canyon and snowing.
And I'm in a expedition,
it's not four wheel drive.
Oh, it's not, okay.
So I was like, the idea
of getting up there
and trying to drive through this snow
and also it being so cold,
I just said, we've got to pull an audible,
we've got to go south.
We're going to miss the Grand Canyon,
this is going to be
another time and place.
Another time, same place,
that we will see the Grand Canyon
and all this other stuff.
So I was scrambling that night,
it was actually the night
we stayed in Amarillo,
I was trying to figure out like,
okay, after we stopped in Albuquerque,
where are we going.
Phoenix?
Well, what I determined was
is there were two really cool things
that I wanted to see if we were
to go south towards Tucson,
and yes, and then in the Phoenix.
Okay.
The first, if you head
south of Albuquerque,
if you're heading towards Tucson,
you can kind of divert off and kind of
go through some crazy wilderness
and see something called
the Very Large Array.
Now, I don't know if you remember,
but when we made the SETI song
and we had like stock
pictures of these satellites
that are just all giant satellites,
like pointing towards the sky,
that's the Very Large Array.
It's the largest array
of radio telescopes.
I think in, definitely North
America, maybe the world.
I said it's 22 miles across
and Locke thought I meant
one satellite that was 22 miles across.
So he was a little bit disappointed
when I showed up there.
It's just 22 miles across
a field, essentially,
of these giant, once you
get right up next to them,
these giant telescopes that are making
all these incredible discoveries of...
You can drive through them?
Well, COVID had closed
down the visitor center,
which also includes a self-guided tour
where you can walk directly
up to one without trespassing.
We did walk pretty much up to one
with a very minor trespassing.
Because it's just as middle of this field,
literally there's cows all around them.
I mean, there's like
cattle grazing out there.
That drive out there is so incredible,
that part of the country is
just beautiful and desolate,
and, I mean, you drive and
drive and drive and drive
and you find like, oh,
there's giant satellites
on these like basically railroad tracks.
It's how they kind of move them around
or like do maintenance on them
because there's railroad tracks
again next to it.
It's all operable, they're
still listening for aliens.
Okay, so I thought that the
whole purpose of the thing
was listening for aliens,
but no, it's a government program where,
it might be private.
The government is
involved, NASA is involved,
because they're using radio telescopes
to discover black holes
and all this information about the galaxy.
So they're constantly scanning the skies,
using radio frequencies,
essentially that's how
radio telescopes work,
mapping and getting pictures of things
using radio frequencies.
And they're incredibly sensitive
and there's a bunch of them.
But SETI, the Search
for Extra Terrestrial,
whatever, that thing that people who are
listening for extra terrestrial
life out in the cosmos,
they've partnered with them
and so they basically have
access to the stream of data
that all these satellites are gathering.
But it's pretty crazy.
I wish we could have
gone in to the gift shop
and gotten some souvenirs,
but we just got some cool pictures.
That was pretty much all we got.
But the goal was to get to a
place called Globe Arizona,
which is in the mountains basically.
Arizona has quite a
landscape, I don't know...
I've never heard of globe.
There's no reason to,
it was just a spot that kind
of made sense for us to get to,
to then be able to go to
our next stop the next day.
But the problem with this
is even though I had,
I was so thankful that we had gone south,
but going through the mountains,
the elevation got up to
like five or 6,000 feet
and we went through like
blizzard conditions.
Really?
Multiple times at night
trying to get to Globe.
And I was like, we stopped and eight
in this middle of nowhere town
and then I'm like looking at
the elevation of where we're at
and elevation of where we
need to get and it's down.
So I'm like, okay, well
it's not going to be
any worse than it is right now.
I didn't know that it
was going to require me
going up higher and then,
so there was like multiple times
where I kind of got to snow,
just like blinding snow,
down the side of a mountain
and I'm freaking out, right?
And Locke is like , "Dad, just relax."
I'm like, "I don't want to get stuck."
Are there other cars driving in this?
Very few, that kept scaring me too.
There's just very few other people
who've made a decision to be on the road.
And so I'm going pretty slow.
It took us a while.
We finally get low enough where
we start seeing some cactus
and we're outside, it's all dark,
I can kind of see them with my headlights,
but we stop and spend
the night in Globe again,
just like, we're just going with
whatever's open at that
point, just some hotel.
You're just ramblers at this point?
It's all blurring together.
But, we were headed for Biosphere 2.
I've got the T-shirt to proof it.
Biosphere 2, I've watched a documentary
all about Biosphere 2.
And we talked about it
pretty extensively on GMM
a couple of years ago as well.
Oh, I didn't, okay,
because I've watched this
much more recently.
It's been years since we
talked about it at GMM.
Because it started in
the '70s, maybe earlier.
No, it was in the '90s.
It was the '90s?
Well-
No.
It was maybe the late '80s, early '90s.
Definitely, they were wearing
like eighties clothes.
I thought it was '70s, definitely '80s.
It was definitely '80s.
It wasn't any earlier than that.
I mean, they may have started
research earlier than that.
But I remember this from when I was a kid.
It's a private-funded biosphere,
self-contained human experiment of,
well, an experiment of sending
these humans into this,
a team, it's kind of like astronauts,
but they're going into his biosphere.
And completely self-contained, so...
And certifying that nothing's
going to go in or out.
Including the air.
So this was basically an experiment
to see if human life can be sustained
in one of these things.
And the applications
could be on another planet
or at the end of the
world, that kind of thing.
So, the atmosphere was
completely self-contained.
The water that they used,
completely self-contained,
they grew their own food,
nothing, for two years,
nothing could come in or out.
Except for the breaches.
Then the press jumped all
over, which is part of the,
the documentary is pretty decent,
I watched it on a plane.
So, knowing a little
bit about the history,
I was like, "Who owns it?"
"Oh, the university of
Arizona owns it now."
I'm like, I wonder if they've
like completely covered,
it says they're using it
actively for research now.
So I was just like,
is this going to be a place that
is embarrassed by the
history of Biosphere?
Because it was kind of a big embarrassment
in a lot of ways, and a
failure in a lot of ways.
Are they going to be embarrassed by it
or are they still like
associated with the same people
and so they're like glossing over
and trying to make it seem
like it was better than it was?
No, they fully embrace
exactly what happened
and they've left a lot of it intact,
including like this is an apartment
where one of the people lived
and you can look inside and see
this is the kitchen,
it's exactly how it was.
So you took a tour inside?
Yes, I went in every part of it.
Oh, how long does that take?
It took us about an hour and a half
and we're moving pretty fast.
Okay, that's pretty cool.
But there's like a rain forest.
You could go outside
and you could spectate,
like you did the Breaking Bad house
and like look through the glass.
and the scientist's working and stuff,
but of course you couldn't go inside
because there were no breaches.
But this was one of the
highlights of the trip.
That cool, because it's huge, right?
It looks huge, like a Puig greenhouse.
Inside is four acres,
which if you can imagine
a house that's four acres,
that's a giant house. People don't...
That's smaller than I thought though.
Well, but if you think about most lots,
if you have an acre of
land in Los Angeles,
that's like 10 times bigger
than everybody else's house.
Oh, sure.
And then if the whole thing
is covered with a house
and you do that times four,
it's massive, once you get inside.
And it's all still working
and all still functional.
They have an indoor ocean,
which at the time they had gone
and collected coral and stuff
and created an active
quote coral reef in there.
The coral reef has died
because at some point
Columbia University owned it
before University of Arizona
and they kind of let
the core coral reef die
for whatever reason,
but it's still there
actively studying some things
and they're actually going to try
to make it a coral reef again.
There's just a number of
like scientific elements
of like the way that the
energy was self-contained
and then there was this giant,
if you see the picture of Biosphere,
there's these giant domes.
You can't go inside those,
but those are basically giant diaphragms,
they're called lungs, to allow,
when the air pressure increases
because of temperature
changes, it expands.
And like it's like a bubble that fills up
to allow the pressure of the air
to not bust the windows out.
Because it's unusual to
have something that's
so self-contained, you've
got to have some way
to let the pressure come and go.
And I do remember from
the documentary that
the inhabitants started
getting really sick
because the oxygen levels were so low
and that's the first thing
where they had to get some
outside help for the oxygen.
The oxygen level ended up
going from like 21 to like 14,
which makes you a little bit
crazy, and it's also dangerous.
Yeah, so it didn't quite
work out, but highly,
and this is right outside of Tucson,
highly recommended stop, if
you find yourself in that area.
And to have a cool T-shirt.
I would like to do that.
Now, the trip is about to come to a close.
Yeah, you're getting close home.
This is the 30th and
the thought was, okay...
Did you have the time
to do the retrospective montage?
No, you've seen quite a bit by this point,
but we got to go through
Phoenix and the idea was,
okay, let's just stop in Phoenix
and then hang out in Phoenix
and see what we can get into
and then we'll stay in Phoenix.
But that was also when we looked
and saw that Phoenix is only
five and a half hours from LA.
The classic, should we
just get home conversation?
Well, it wasn't like we weren't
going to stop at Phoenix,
it was like, do we need
to stay in Phoenix?
Let's just get home late and
just sleep in our own beds.
So we kind of determined to do that,
but there's a couple of
things about Phoenix.
I don't think I've ever been to Phoenix.
I've been around it,
they've got a big Belt line.
Maybe we stopped there
for a tour or something.
I don't remember everywhere we've been,
but like fifth largest city in America.
Did you know that?
Could not have told you that.
Behind like LA, New York,
Chicago, and I guess Boston.
You're talking about square footage?
People.
People?
Yes, and it's also because
it includes like Scottsdale
and some other places that you
may have heard of as a city,
but it's also really just...
Fifth largest?
It's a giant.
The thing I noticed about Phoenix is,
nothing against any of the
other places that I've visited,
but Phoenix is the first
place where I was like,
began to recognize like...
You're searching for the
diplomatic word to say this.
What is it?
I'll just say hipsters.
Okay.
I wasn't going to say cool people.
But I started to feel that
there was a proximity...
A hipster contingent here not
experienced after Nashville.
Nashville has a hipster component
but when you go to the
downtown area of Nashville,
it's like going to Hollywood, California.
It's like Hollywood, Boulevard.
No one's from there, except maybe...
So, you found that in Phoenix?
Yeah.
Some too good for their
own good coffee shops?
Yeah, we're talking in
coffee shops, breweries,
we ate at this place called,
I think it was The Wilderness Brewery
and it was like a bunch of hipsters there
and it felt very at home.
So you might be eyeing Phoenix, huh?
Well, the thing is, it was Roosevelt road,
which is kind of like their arts district,
and it was really cool,
and then I was like, oh,
Phoenix is like a cool place
that we could come on for like a weekend.
because it's the same just
driving to San Francisco,
it's not that bad.
But then I started looking at
the average daily temperature
throughout the year
and there's like six or seven months
where it's like a hundred.
It's a hot place, you know?
So I don't know how they
deal with that exactly
besides just going inside.
But it seems like there's some
good times to visit Phoenix.
But one of the things that I
skipped over in terms of music
is somewhere at this part of the trip
is when I'm beginning to think, like,
I've got to introduce
Locke to some other stuff.
And that was when I was like,
"Oh, you know what?
I think you'll like Diamond Rio."
After George Strait, yeah.
Because I was like,
speaking in '90s country,
I was like, there was these guys
that Link and I were really, really into,
and they kind of, I'm
not going to call them
a flash in the pan.
They're still together and
they're still making music,
but the '90s, they peaked
pretty hard in the '90s.
They had three really solid albums.
I don't know, I would say four,
had some really good hits.
And they had a, I don't know
if they were number ones,
they probably were because
they had some incredible songs, right?
Bluegrass infused '90s
country, lots of harmony.
The vocal approach is the thing
that is so notable about them.
And I would say that
yes, to the bluegrass niche of it all,
but it doesn't have that,
it doesn't get into bluegrass
sort of chord structure and tempo.
It's like kind of country,
rocky with this...
Infused.
This singing, and I could
just look on Locke's face
as we were listening to
Love a Little Stronger
and then One More Day,
wait, didn't have One More
Day play at your wedding?
♪ One more day♪
No, that's talking about
if Somebody died, Rhett.
It's, I Know How the River Feels.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But one more day, man...
When you meet your soulmate
and they're still living.
Okay, well, we'll play it
One More Day at your funeral.
One More Day is a great song. So Locke...
There're so many great songs.
So from that point in the trip,
so this is like the last two days,
he just kept wanting to go back
to those four or five really
amazing Diamond Rio songs.
And then he's like texting
me recently and was like,
"Dad, we've got to go to
a Diamond Rio concert."
So he's all in on Diamond Rio.
Yeah, definitely top five country artists.
I think I might have to put
them in my top five of artists,
not just, I mean, definitely
groups and definitely, '90s.
Okay, so we're on day five and
we have driven quite a bit,
but we're also kind of saying
let's sleep in our own beds
and we just go ahead and we make the trip.
Power through.
We get back to LA at like 10:30 at night
and let me just say that
Locke and I are very similar
in a lot of ways, which is
a recipe for fights, right?
And we did not get into,
and of course he's 17.
Like when we're at home in
our normal everyday lives
where there's things like,
you didn't take the trash out.
There's these lots of little things
that could then turn into an argument,
but we got through this trip
without any sort of friction.
We were having an
incredible time together.
Listening to music, seeing this stuff,
we talked about pretty much everything.
Philosophy, everything and
where we were listening to
one of my favorite books, Siddhartha,
which I listened to on my solo trip
and it was something that he
had been wanting to listen to
which is just short audio
books, really easy to listen to.
So, we were having this incredible time
and then like 20 minutes from home
is when we got into our
first like argument.
And it was like, it
escalated really quickly,
I don't even remember what it was about,
and then I was like,
listen, there's no reason
for us to fight right now.
Let's just get home, let's just get home
and just forget about this and we did.
First of all, multiple
times throughout the trip,
he was like, "I'm so glad I did this.
I was wrong, I'm glad
you talked me into this."
He's telling everybody about it
and how good of a time he had.
It is the kind of thing that
he's going to remember forever.
And I think is more
likely to now lead to us
doing another trip together,
maybe for a spring break,
we don't know exactly
what we're going to do.
But it was a success,
a father-son success.
Is there a point where you went like,
"Okay, well, what'd you learn, son?
What are you going to remember forever?"
Well, one of the things
that I've come to grips with is
every dad, most dads, I think,
have a tendency to dadify things,
and to try to find the lesson
or the moral in something
and like my kids have become...
To codify something to feel
there is an impulse to like,
let's land this plane
and I am doing a good job as a dad.
It's a question that you seek the answer,
I think that drives that.
Well, the thing that has
become very clear to me
is that that is for me
only, that's not for Locke.
Yeah, right.
That exercise is 100% for my own ego.
And own sense of security or...
Yeah, it could be.
And I'm using ego broadly.
So, and I actually made the decision,
there's no lecturing,
there's no trying to get him
to see something a
certain way on this trip.
Now, what I found is that he
actually is very interested
in what I think about things,
he's very interested in my opinion.
And when I don't use every conversation
as a jumping off point for some lesson
or for giving him some perspective,
he just naturally asks
me or runs things by me
in a way that it's very
clear that what he's after
is what I think about this.
Now, I have to be really careful
once I start talking about those things
to not turn it into a lecture
and to make it more a, well, I mean,
one way to see that is this,
or here's one thing that
I would think about.
We really had some really
great conversations
about a lot of things
that we kind of talk about
from time to time
but in the setting of this,
where there's no place to go,
we've got to kill time,
it lent itself to those
kinds of conversations
and he was very much all for it.
I mean, it was great for our relationship.
And now that we're back in the
swing of just regular life,
yes, there's been some arguments again,
but I think that there's a connection
that already there, of course,
but it was just strengthened
and enhanced through this.
So, I highly recommended
if you have the opportunity
to take a trip.
With my son.
That's my trip.
My rec is one other, is the
album that we listened to
more than any album that we
both just fell in love with.
I think I have told you about this guy,
but I don't know how much
you've listened to him, Brent Cobb.
Yeah.
He's got a song that's really popular,
like Keep Them on their
Toes or something like that.
Yeah.
And like any artist,
there are some albums or some songs
that don't really resonate,
but he's got an album
from a few years back
called Shine on a Rainy Day.
And this is the one that
we just centered in on
and I like his most recent album as well,
but he's a south Georgia boy,
who's born very close to where I was born,
he's got a song about, I
think called South of Atlanta,
which is about going back to his hometown
and I think he now lives,
he was in Nashville for a while,
but now he lives down
there in South Georgia.
It's a laid back, this album?
Yeah, that's the thing,
is that he'll go a little
bit rock in some places,
which is why I don't like as much,
on this album is almost exclusively,
just like thoughtful sort
of soulful, good country.
And again, this isn't the kind of country
you're going to hear on country radio.
This is way better than that.
And it's just so amazing to me
that they don't play
this music on the radio,
but Brent Cobb, Georgia boy, huge fan.
Shine on a Rainy Day just
starts off with a song
about sitting on a porch
and solving the problems of the world
and he just goes on from there.
So that's my rec.
Great road trip music,
but also just great music in general.
I'm glad he had him, glad he made it.
Yeah, relationship didn't fall off.
Not only intact,
but you've got some memories
that will last his lifetime.
Of course, you're going
to pass on at some point
and then you'll live on
a little bit of how to
live on in his memory.
That's true and in video form,
for those of you who watched the video.
There's a lot to see,
that Link didn't even get to see.
You're going to have to watch this.
You've got to watch this one.
Oh yeah, I'll watch it.
All right, we'll talk to you next week.
#EarBiscuits weigh in.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical Best.